Herkese merhabalar hoş geldiniz Ben de
hoş geldi menfezi rothia gelmemiştim otu
benim hayalim de bir zamanlar Çünkü
benim kolejde okudum yıllar Koleji
bitiren doğal olarak sanki okeye girerdi
Bir sınıfta 29 Kişiydik 27 sochi'ye
girdi biz iki kişi sap gibi kaldık o iki
kişide tıp fakültesine girdik hiç
unutmuyorum tıp fakültesinde çok zor lan
Mıştım bizim Koleji pek benzemiyordu
arada bir kaçar o thy'ye gelirdim
buradaki arkadaşlarını görmeye şimdi
aradan yıllar geçti bugün geldi bugün
benim doğum günüm burada
Evet arkadaşlarım bunları hatırlamış çok
teşekkür ediyorum Bana pastalar kestiler
Bunlar yapmışlar falan çok güzel çok
hatırlamak kısa bir ayrı bir güzel
burada size anlatmak istediğim Aslında
size kadar motifin anlatmaya geldim
buraya güzel bir kavram yıllardır çok
üzerinde çalıştığım neredeyse kafayı
taktığım bir kavram ona geçmeden önce
beni o kavrama nasıl yolla geldim size
kısaca kendimden söz etmek istiyorum
işte Koleji bitti ben 30 il tıp
fakültesine girdim Çünkü ailem benim
Doktor olmam da kararlıydı o nedenle çok
Sen ne istiyorsun falan diye sormadılar
bana
bu tıp fakültesine derse başladım yıl
radyoda bir anlamda spikerliğe başladım
bir anonsla gittim arkasından şu TRT
televizyonu kurulduğu arkasından işte
Ben orta spiker ama o spikeri daha sonra
tüm programlarda sonucu filan derken Tıp
Fakültesi orada bitti Şimdi dönüp
bakınca Ben de çok şaşıyorum yazması
olmuş yerde Fakültesi gibi bir okul bir
yandan da her akşam çalışarak bitter
miymiş bir de üst seriyi de bir
öğrenciydi orada filan öyle çalışırdım
Annem akşamları ben gece yarılarına
kadar seni evde ders çalışıyorum vakit
kalmamış ki böyle ben çalışırken
üzülürdü bir kahve yapar gelirdin yanıma
Hadi gel bir kahve içelim seninle hem de
şu kapat da falına bakayım derdi Aman ne
kadar hoşuma giderdi hemen kapatırdım şu
ne olur açardı O sen boşları çalışma
canım Şahane sen işte nas8 alacaksın her
şey güzel silah beni Doldur Doldur beni
moralim harika olur Hakikaten de onun
dediği botlarını almayı bir şekilde
başardım şimdi Buradan şuraya gelmek
istiyorum al al hani bütün insanlar fal
İşine çok meraklıdır falda ne ararız
arkadaşlar ne acaba verdiği Önümüzdeki
günler gelecekte benim başıma neler
gelecek Nasıl bir hayatım olacak işte
hep Bitmez Tükenmez hayallerimiz var bu
hayalleri hayata geçirebilecek miyim
işte öyle olacak mı sevgilim işte beni
arayacak mı O sınavı geçebilecek miyim
silah böyle hepimizin hayalleri var Ben
psikiyatri Başladığım zaman şimdi
gelirken parmak hesabı yaptım tam 40
bu çıktı Şimdi siz de parmak hesabıyla
benim kaç yaşında olduğumu aşağı yukarı
bulacaksınız 47 yüzdür psikiyatriyle
haşır neşir olmak çok değişik bir yol
açıyor insanın önüne Bir de ben mesleği
iyi çok kötü severek yapanlardan biriyim
her ne kadar Ben seçmedim SD Hayat Benim
adıma beni bu mesleğe getirdi ay diyorum
ya çok şükür Ne kadar doğru bir yere
getirmiş beni Çünkü İnsanın sevdiği işi
yaparak yaşaması çok güzel bir şey ben
şimdi bu çok genç yaşımda Madem doğum
günü ve hala bu mesleği yapmaktan büyük
bir haz alıyorum çünkü bu meslek beni
çok değişik kesimlerden gelen çok
değişik insanlarla bir araya getirdi o
insanlarla her Bengü
bu odalarıma hep muhabbet adını veririm
muhabbet yani ibadet edilen yer Ben
çalışmak Hele ki insana hizmet etmeyi de
ibadet gibi görenlerden biri lo görüşme
odasında Allah nerelere gider geliriz ve
bana insanlar ne pencereler açtılar
Hayatın benim hiç bilmediğin ne
yüzlerini gösterdiler harfi lan biz o
var Sen çok karanlık çok acı dolu falan
Bazen çok hoş da yollarda gezerken
gezerken gezerken insanların
zihinlerinin içindeki o dehlizlerde
gezerken şensan ki bir matematik orada
var vardı ya da yok yani arada bir bana
yüzünü gösteriyor arada bir kaçıyor
derken Ben peşine düştüm Ne bu çünkü bu
psikiyatri biliyorsunuz insanların
geçmişine öğrenmeyi çok
bu karikatürlerde bile derler ya anlat
bakalım bana çocukluğumu diye Çünkü bir
insanın nereden geldiğini ve onu tüm
detaylarıyla özellikleriyle Bir
psikiyatrist bilebilir görebilirse ancak
o zaman onu tanır ve ona ona uygun
şeyleri söyleyebilir zaten Bir
psikiyatrist ve hasta arasında Hani
psikoterapide dediğimiz olay
gerçekleşirken çok sıkı Çok yakın çok
sıcak bir dostluk bir sırdaşlık da
gelişir ve işte ben orada bir matematik
bir şey var ama ne filan son yıllarını
tamamen bu adına Kader motifi taktı
kavram üzerinde çalışma ile geçirdim
akşama kadar böyle çok bir insanı
dinliyorum bundan onbeş onaltı yıl önce
de yazmaya başladım kitapları o
kitapları
12 ama amacım vardı birincisi di insan
bu çok değişik insanlarla çok yakın
ilişki içinde vakit geçirirse hayatın
çok farklı yüzlerini görebiliyor dedim
ki ben madem bu kadar değişik şeyleri
bana insanlar öğretti ben de bunları
yazayım ki başka insanlarda bunu
öğrensinler iki o üzerinde çalıştığım
Kader motiflerini bu kitaplarda
bulsunlar yani okurken okurken kitabın
bir yerinde kendi ile karşılaşabilirsin
Çünkü ben hastalığımı dinlerken onların
anlattığı hikayelerin hemen her birinde
bir yerlerde hep kendimle karşılaşmış
ımdır ha Ben kendimle karşılaşa
biliyorsam işte ben de bunu kendi
duygularımı da katarak yazarsak başkası
da kendini orada görebilir bu
yeni başladım yazmaya şimdi aradan onbeş
onaltı yıl geçti şimdi görüyorum ki
yavaş yavaş benim Kitaplarımı tanımaya
başladı insanlar Evet kendilerini
bulmaya başlamışlar bana böyle mesajlar
ya uyu mektuplar geliyor müthiş bir şey
bu tabi Böylece ben de bir yandan
ilerliyorum Kader motifi Yani bugünden
Geleceği nasıl bakabiliriz şimdi kadar
motifini çok güzel açılımı bu kavramı
çok kısa anlatmak çok zor ama ben en net
haliyle sizlere bunu Anlatmaya
çalışacağım Evet haliyle kadar motifi şu
bir bebek dünyaya geldiği zaman bir
düşmüş yani sıfır bir şekilde Dünyaya
Geliyor bomboş bir tek şeyi biliyor
yardım istemeyi ağlamayı biliyor
o Çünkü onun beyninde birtakım Biz boş
diyoruz ama bizim zannettiğimiz kadar da
boş gelmiyoruz dünyaya bir takım kodları
var iş içgüdüler dediğimiz kınıkkoz anıp
gönderiyor yaratan veya dua ediyor O
içgüdüler şunları diyorlar bir kere
diyor ki ölme ölmeyeceksin ölmemek
hayatta kalabilmek için elinden ne
gelirse yapacaksın ama onu becerdin size
daha sonra da işte şunları isteyeceksin
şimdi bir saymaya başlayacağım Siz de
şaşıracaksınız şaşmayın biz böyleyiz
zaten işte bütün dünya seni sevsin
Herkes seni tanısın herkes sana saygı
itibar göstersin her şeyin en iyisi
senin olsun senin canını isterse her
şeyi bu dünya sana versin vermedi mi Vur
kır öldür ortalığı dat işte bütün cinsel
isteklerine cevap versin Yani o kadar
bence
o toplarımız var ki ne dünyaya
geldiğimizde ise şimdi Kader motifinin
birinci ayağı İşte bu insanın içinde
bizi kodlayarak Üçümüzde taşıyarak
geldiğimiz bir tarafta bu istekler
duruyor şimdi dünyaya geldik ya bundan
başka bir şey bilmiyoruz orada Zavallı
bir bebek kenarda bir tek ağlamayı
biliyor o bebeğin iki önemli uykusu var
biri korku bir huzur korku ne ona
tehlike yaratan her şeye ağlayarak tepki
verecek ve yardım isteyecek eğer kendini
tehlikede istiyorsa bebek hissediyorsa
bebek hep ağlayacak Eğer tehlike yoksa
çok huzur bulacak Bunu kim temin eder
anne ya da anne geçir yerine geçen kişi
Eğer bu çocuğa
ve yeteri kadar iyi bakıyor onu hiç
korkutmuyor Onun bütün ihtiyaçlarını
önceden görüp yerine getiriyorsa ve
çocukta bu korku duygusu pek de
olmayacak hep huzurla geçecek Beka
matheus ise evde Ortalık birbirine
giriyor 40 tane çocuk var zaten Hale'nin
çocuktan başka bir tane işi var O da
işte bir şekilde büyürse büyüyecek
büyümezse Allah kerim bir tane daha
verir Allah inşallah böyle bir durumda
da büyüyebilir O zaman nasıl olacak Hep
korku duygusuyla yaşayacak Şimdi ben sen
meseleler Kendinizi çok kaba bir ayırım
şöyle ayırabiliriz Bazı insanlar sanki
doğuştan huzurludur Büşra hayatın sorunu
biter mi Bitmez ama o kadar olumlu bakar
ki ama susayan çok şükür şimdiye kadar
idare ettik Bu da bir şekilde geçer de
ve tevekkül içinde Gamsız ve huzurlu
olarak yaşamaya devam eder bazıları da
bana gelir der ki hocam benim her şeyim
var beni mutlu olmamak için hiçbir
eksiğim yok ama ben yine de huzursuzum
her an başıma bir şey mi Gelecek Allahım
şu bulacak bum olacak telefon çalacak da
kötü bir haberim geleceğim bakın Kader
motifinin Ayak seslerini duymaya
başladınız herhalde değil mi orada
yazılmaya başlıyor şimdi bebeğin içinde
sürekli kayıt yapan bir bilgisayar var
ama bu o kadar gelişmiş bir bilgisayar
ki biz de zannediyoruz ki orada yatan
bebek bir şeyden anlamaz yandan şey
konuşabiliriz yapabiliriz Halbuki o öyle
bir kayıt cihazına sahip keke yaşamam o
evde O ev neresi Hani doğduğum ev
kaderimdir diye bir dizi var ya şu anda
benim yazdığım kitaptan uyarlama
mi Evet o ev bizim kaderimiz yazıyor
çünkü o evin Dünyası O bilgisayar için
hayatı temsil ediyor Oraya bakarak diyor
ki benim isteklerim Bunlar dünya ki
dünyada bu işte TV onları süratle
kaydediyor ve İçindeki duyguları da en
iyi kaydediyor duygulara şöyle bir renk
verecek olursak Bak işte Efendim
beyazdan siyaha kadar götürelim bütün
renkler İşte en güzel duygular Kırmızı
olsun işte kötüler siyah olsun yok O yok
bir şeyin içine depolamaya başlıyor
Neyse ben Kader motifin rengini böyle
tayin ediyorum Diyorum ki yaşadığımız
evde Bizim içimizdeki Bilgisayarım hayd
ettiği o duyguları şöyle bir
çalkalayınca ortaya hangi renk çıkarsa
Kader motifin izin rengi i
de budur bir çocuğun tepkilerine dış
dünyadan bir cevap geliyor Ben çocuk
bağırıyor ağlıyor Karnım aç altın pis
işte ben karnım ağrıyor iyi değilim
filan hepsini tek bir tepkiyle
verebiliyor ve etraftan ses yok veya
Aman sen ağlama Ben hep buradayım diyen
bir anne şimdi buna göre dünya hakkında
bir fikir sahibi oluyor O bilgisayar ve
sonuç olarak bilgisayarın amacı ne
kendini yani orada bir sistem kuruluş
sistem kendini yaratmaya çalışıyor bunu
yaratmak için zeriye ihtiyacı var Bu
taraftaki veriler elde zaten diğerleri
dünyada değil dünyaya verdiği
tepkilerden diğer verileri de kaydediyor
ben bunlarla bunun nasıl uyuşturabilirim
acaba diye bir
bu oluşturmaya gayret ediyor da da işte
Bilgisayarım o sisteme yaratırken
yarattığı ne bizim kişiliğimiz o sistemi
yaratırken ortaya çıkan ilk çekirdek
şablon Neyse bizim Kader motif imiz odur
Çünkü u çekirdek Ben de ona özellikle
motif diyorum sürekli kendini tekrar
ederek bu bir yazılım Çünkü şeye yazılım
yaptığınız zaman onu değiştirmezseniz
yazılım başka bir şey veriyor mu size
vermiyor ve böylece o ilk yazılım bir
kader motifi olarak sizin bu gününüzü
günümüzü ve geleceğimizi yazmış oluyor
Böylece çocukken aldığınız yaraların
sizi götürdüğü yere gidiyorsunuz ya da
bu
O bir cümlem daha vardır benim Bizler
çocukluk açı larımızı bize yatıyor
yeniden yaşatacak kişileri gözünden
tanır ve gider başkasına değil ona aşık
oluruz niye çok acı vardı yani birçok
acılarla büyüdük benliğine oraya
gidiyorum sistem öbürü tanımıyor onun
tanıdığı acı onun tanıdığı şiddet onun
tanıdığı hor görülmek Böylece seçimi her
zaman o tanıdığı şeyler üzerinden
yapıyor ve böylece Kaderimiz yazılmış
oluyor Ben son olarak bak dünya insanlık
bugün geldiği yeri düşünecek olursak İlk
insan ne yapıyorsa bir anlamda işte
farkımız yok ya bu kadar gelişen dünya
dayız ve hala savaşıyoruz hala b
bu tükenmez savaş var hala şiddet tüm
dünyada kol geziyor E şimdi bu Üstelik
bu çift nesilden nesile de geçmeye devam
eden bir şey yani Birisi eşini
öldürüyorsa sokak ortasında o adamın
motifi nerede yazıldı o evde kim
yansıttığı en çok yaralayanlar en çok
yaralı olanlardır o zaman bütün bir
nesil zaten bu şiddet zincirinin devamı
olarak gelmiş O nedenle bu motifi hep
birlikte tanımaya çalışalım ki hem bizim
kaderimiz hem de çocuklarımızın kaderi
güzel olsun teşekkür ederim beni
dinlediğiniz fen